now let's hear from the girls do you
think most girls are objective or do you
think they think they're hotter than
they are
or do they underrate themselves go
around personally i think it depends on
the person because growing up i'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone i'm not
skinny so growing up i was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted by
people blah blah blah blah and i was
just the other one you know so like i
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like i would never
call myself anything more than a fault
but
now like i don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like i've
grown into myself and i've i've i'm
comfortable with who i am now that like
even if you guys call me delusion or
whatever i think i'm
maybe not 10 let's not go that far but
like definitely an eight
so like
whether you guys think i am or not
yeah that's got nothing to do with her
but like what is it that took you from a
four to an eight if nothing's changed
what is it that takes loving myself and
and looking in the mirror and not
being disgusted at what i see i
understand that yeah so
but that doesn't you're you're not
necessarily being objective about how
other people view you right because
isn't that what a rating really is like
what you think the vast majority like
like if i rated myself one to ten i give
myself a five i think i'm normal looking
and i just think it's based on my
results i think if i was an eight nine
or ten i would have had modeling
contracts because people in the top
twenty percent of beauty they get they
get modeling contracts
so what what is beauty i mean there's a
lot of things like if you
i mean you can you can go online and
have people rate your pictures and they
they rank you one to 10. that's wild and
so you can get you can get a lot of data
that says how attractive you are in
society and men will wait you women will
rate you like every day
how we look is like how we represent
ourselves it's not fun but it's just
like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can take get
dating apps to like you know everyone's
tinder bumble like they have a ranking
for you behind the scenes
yeah damn yeah well
so
um
i don't understand when girls say like
i'm an eight because or sometimes i hear
girls say time because i hear this a lot
where they say like because i love
myself and i'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but i don't care about those
results
to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective
about your how attractive you are or how
attractive anyone else might be
um
i guess not but
i think yeah
that stuff's not really important to me
i think when when someone
when someone rates somebody
why sh why does that have anything to do
with them
like if you rate me if someone rated
like somebody a three and it's just like
okay that's that's your opinion like
it's not like a rating is not a fact
it's an opinion
what do you know what i mean everyone's
opinion then well but in fact yeah add
up to a consensus maybe not a fact yeah
consensus yeah
yeah but i think
like i have a group of friends right and
when i walk into the room with a group
of friends i know immediately who's
going to get the most attention from the
guys
it's it's not me right i have like a
friend who's like very very attractive
and i know when i walk into a room with
her like the guys talk to her first
because like girls you can kind of just
feel it but i almost
wonder when i hear like and i hear this
from girls a lot like i'm a 10 i'm a 10
i'm a tent
if that's not like rooted in reality
because attractiveness like there's
numbers behind it whether it's just your
results in the world or your dating app
data or
the like the type of guys you can get
a tough one it's not um like
i don't enjoy like walking into a room
and knowing everyone's gonna talk to my
friend and not me that's not fun
but i think i'd be delusional if i if i
thought if i walked into a room and i
thought
wow like they're all gonna talk to me
first
i think in addition to your point men
understand hierarchy i was just gonna
say that so we understand that
i'm a four because there are guys that
are five and get this attention guys
there are six they get that attention
seven and so on and so forth whereas
women um
i don't wanna say they live in a
delusion sometimes but it's a case of
well i
because i believe i'm this i am that
and i was going to speak about gender
but i thought let me not because there's
there's a whole
separate topic where
people will go oh
what is gender
and then yeah
yeah
but i think i do think that women also
understand hierarchy it's just like
in this day and age
because we've been exposed to what
men want
we kind of understand like oh okay
that's not what men want but i don't
care i'm not i'm never going to be that
you know
without
money
and
and clout shall i say what do you what
do you guys think men want
kim kardashian body well let's ask y'all
i want to hear because you said like you
think that girls understand what men
want so i want to go like one by one
and do you think what do you think men
want
no one at a time sorry
i i couldn't tell you because
i feel like
again i've never been in a relationship
but i've chatted to quite a few guys and
it seems like it's not even that i don't
live up to their standards i feel like
i'm never what they want and i'm like is
it looks okay apparently i checked that
box but they still don't want me there's
a personality yeah you're cool you're
vibes but i don't want to wife you like
i don't i don't get it you say you want
personality but you still go and try and
treat a girl like a hoe and i know this
is not all guys i understand that maybe
this is just the guys i attract i don't
know what i'm doing but
okay cool
but i just feel like maybe
society as a whole not everyone
we do care a lot about looks and i think
that is a lot about
like the fact it's just it's very
superficial i think a lot of guys are
very superficial again not all guys
but maybe a certain kind of guys
they just care more about looks could i
give you some advice in regards to like
dealing with a guy that you're not sure
where you stand with him where he's
saying like he might have sex with you
but he's not willing to commit to you or
he might you know take you out on dates
or you might cook dinner for him or you
you might take him on dates you know
whatever it is yeah but there's no
commitment there's no
long-standing chance of a relationship
yeah if you're dealing with that kind of
situation i say i think there's one
sentence that would clear up the whole
thing would you like to meet my dad
bang what if you don't have
okay fair enough but would you like to
meet my family would you like to meet my
brother would you like to meet my mum
as soon as you take it there i'm sorry
but there's an immediate decision that
that partner has to make i'm actually
serious about this
do i want to am i invested in this
person enough to actually engage with
their family yeah so and honestly
from the beginning if you introduce your
boyfriend your fling whatever it is if
you're trying to get commitment from
them if you introduce them to your
family from the beginning
yeah you can see how they engage with
your family members yeah are they
respectful especially a male counterpart
in the family absolutely because they
can tell
what that guy is up to but what if you
don't have a meal
that's
what if you
i understand that there are other
circumstances obviously i would still
say introduce them to your family do you
have a trusted elder brother type figure
or a father type figure that you trust
if you don't
you know many moms out there have played
the role of both father and mother right
even your friend who's the guy sorry
even your friend who is a guy
about that one yeah yeah i don't know
about that one no no no because yeah
your friend who's a guy might be
actually that's your boy they're gonna
you know sorry
because he wants you yeah yeah yeah
exactly so he may not be very objective
about it
family member will be so
um what do you guys think that men want
i kind of agree with eyes ties like it's
kind of weird um
some guys might just actually just want
looks or body
um some guys want to see like where the
girl's going in the career or what she's
actually interested in some guys i don't
know
um
okay they might have some
similarities or certain i did i don't
know i don't actually know what about
you
um
from what i've gathered from from guys
that have been interested in me
um as well as like guy friends
um
most of the time they don't want a
plus-sized girl because
either they're afraid
or embarrassed or they're afraid or
whatever
um
or if they do they only want to be
low-key about it they don't want to show
you off they don't want people to know
that they're that they're
like talking to you or trying to do a
thing with you
but
most of the the guy friends
that i've had usually want
like
girls definitely big bum it's always a
big bum
always always always
and then but the thing is most of the
time they want the big bum but they
don't want the the the things that come
with the big bum like the natural stuff
that comes with yeah the outward glass
yeah
they want the the nice boom like figure
so i want to hear from the guys
um what what do you guys what do you all
want if you guys wanted to get married
what would you look for in a wife
do you want to go home
[Laughter]
i'm going to get hate for this but
submissiveness submission oh that's okay
oh okay that's fine okay for me um
look i'm a muslim
i'm i i may not be religious but i try
to be
submission isn't the word that i
tend to use
you're like if a woman is submissive to
god then she will do her duty as a wife
yeah what i require from a wife is fun
if there's one word is cooperativeness
what does that mean that you have a wife
a partner
that is gonna ride or die with you
towards the same goal towards the same
end yeah
that is the fundamental quality that i
require from a woman
beauty will fade
facts beauty will fade not undertale not
all the time look there are some
50-year-old women out there that still
got a god bless them yeah yeah right
right
but listen cooperativeness
like are you going to be holding it down
you know whilst i'm struggling at work
or
you know if there's kids at home crying
and screaming are you gonna give up easy
what kind of character do you have do
you have resilience do you have like the
ability to give me peace when i need it
are you gonna be able to take care of
things
as i need you to when i need you to yeah
like
i'm not saying have a woman like at the
end of a whip yo do this for me do that
for me no no no
is that
what was that
[Laughter]
the main thing i think is just that
fundamental cooperativeness that we
agree towards the same similar goal or
the same goal and that we're both
gunning for that together now we might
have separate roles
when gunning for that same goal yeah but
the goal is the same and if she's on
board that's it yeah i agree what about
you um
you said a lot of things as well so but
like just to add on to what you guys
said i i just want peace i want someone
that can bring me peace when i come back
from the world
um that i'm having to fight in order to
kind of bring
something
to the table um
from your answers ladies it sounded like
you girls didn't really know what men
want
i didn't say anything
fair enough fair enough well so like
that would more indicate you don't know
what men want and when i ask you the
question you say nothing no thank you to
be fair they they answered so and then
it continued
hey all right but yeah it
it sounds like you have an indication of
what you think men want and you're doing
the things that you think men want and
then you're not getting the results
exact of what you want